meantime South Korea's foreign minister
says his country's president moon jae-in
is confident that the talks could lead
to the denuclearization of North Korea
moon declared the plan summit a
historical milestone he had previously
called for diplomacy between the north
and the US Holly Williams is in Seoul
while there is also skepticism about the
benefits of a meeting Holly good morning
good morning well the current
administration here in South Korea wants
to engage with North Korea but many
other people here say that the North
simply cannot be trusted and will never
give up its nuclear weapons on the face
of it North Korea does seem to have made
some concessions it's agreed to talk
about denuclearization and it says it
will freeze its nuclear and missile
tests but that's reversible and if these
talks go ahead then the reward for North
Korea is huge because if a sitting US
president meets with North Korea's
dictator Kim jong-un then that helps
give him some credibility in the eyes of
the world which is exactly what North
Korea craves remember also that North
Korea has reneged on previous deals all
the while continuing to develop its
nuclear weapons and the the big question
in this part of the world is just how
far China will go to enforce sanctions
and forced North Korea to denuclearize
China has been cracking down but for
years it's been North Korea's biggest
trading partner and a lifeline for the
regime John Holly Williams in Seoul
Thank You Holly